en france patrick dils vit des heures
cruciales il sera demain s'il est
acquitté ou à nouveau condamné
aujourd'hui le procureur n'a demandé
aucune peine aucune condamnation à son
encontre
il requiert le bénéfice du doute à la
cour d'assises du rhône stéphanie perez
et jérémie drieu embarrassé françois
louis coste l'avocat général quand il
arrive
d'un côté il y à ses aveux répétés de
patrick dils inhumain fiche détaillée
qu'ils en sont insupportables voyez vous
dit il en pointant du doigt il y à 16
ans si j'avais eu à requérir j'aurais
demandé votre condamnation
seulement voilà il n'y a pas de mobile
les repères chronologiques sont
incertains et francis heaulme était là
le doute est omniprésent pendant les
trois heures d'exposé un doute tels que
l'avocat général ne retiennent ils
acquittement ni la condamnation
un fait rare dans les annales
judiciaires si le doute l'emportent 2
races patrick dils ne venait pas
disputer la place de victimes
vous avez pris la place du meurtrier
vous n'êtes victimes que de vous même il
laisse les jurés dans un abîme de
réflexion propos qui est
son abîme à lui avocat général
qui est de se dire malgré trois semaines
de débats je ne peux pas quitter l'habit
du doubs qui n'a pas le courage de
prononcer le terme d'acquis pour tous
pour protéger l'institution judiciaire
ça évite de mettre en cause
l'institution judiciaire en termes de
responsabilités ça évite de parler des
roches aunisiens cave équipements et on
fait deux tours retomber la faute sur un
gamin de 16 ans les familles des deux
enfants elles sont plutôt déçus on
comprend très bien parce que quand on
dit ça quand on dit comment les gosses
ont été tués avec élection verrerie
qu'ils ont effectué tout ça me convient
nous dire non on va voir au pdc du tout
encore plus très bien vu
nous sommes dans une incertitude
certaines en quelques mots l'avocat
général a résumé les des new deal tout
repose donc désormais sur les épaules
des 12 jurés
demain ils devront choisir entre le
bénéfice du doute et leur intime
conviction